the other day someone said that I needed
like a plant or something to make my set
a little more interesting so here we go
some leeks have come out about the
iPhone 11 it's definitely gonna be
called the iPhone Pro according to these
articles I don't know anything I only
know what I google and read on the
Internet
this article is saying that there's a
massive iPhone 11 leak it confirms 11
new features so I'll put a link to this
article in the description if you want
to read it more thoroughly but here are
the 11 things number one Apple is
abandoning its short-lived Roman
numerals and changing the way that you
talk to your phones 2 pro which
completely makes sense because we follow
the naming scheme of all of their other
products Pro is something that is very
commonly used and it just makes sense I
feel like they're naming conventions
sometimes got a little bit confusing
anyway so maybe this will help
maybe it won't I don't know but I'm
gonna get the phone and that's all it
matters to me this one I really like the
stove top which is really funny that
that's what they're calling this it
looks like a freaking stove I love it so
much
whoever originally came up with that I'm
into the name but this is cool because
it's saying that the cameras will work
at the same time so it'll be capturing
three pictures at the same time so every
time you take a photo all those cameras
will be firing and taking shots so if
the main camera cuts out a person who's
captured wide angle you can add them
back in I think this is great because
there's a lot of times that I've always
been wanting to shoot both vertical and
horizontal videos at the same time one
for Instagram and one of the Twitter so
that is something that would be really
really cool if that's actually possible
it might be possible I'm not sure I
think honestly anything's possible at
this point you know that brings us to
number three video recording has
significantly upgrade the iPhone 11 is
now closer to professional video cameras
that's kind of that's kind of hard to
say because a professional video camera
you can swap out lenses yes there are
three cameras in this so that would
technically give you three different
camera angles or camera lenses but I'm
here for it there are so many times that
I end up just foregoing bringing a
massive camera and just so many things
on my iPhone because a lot of times I
will take a picture with my iPhone and
it ends up looking better than my $6,000
camera rig that I would normally be
lugging around not always but there are
times that you just press that button
and you're like oh my phone yeah
therefore reverse wireless charging
something we've talked about before so
this isn't really that new information
but this is something that I'm excited
about mostly because there are times
that I might need to charge something
like someone else's phone feel like
that's what I'm always doing this is
also something that's interesting a
matte finish on the iPhones I will say
that this is the most perfect looking
phone I think that Apple has ever made
this gold is perfect just the sheen just
everything about it it's so freaking
perfect it says that Apple will retain
some traditional glossy finishes as well
Hossein we don't know we don't know
these are all just rumors even though
these numbers look pretty legit to me
improved shadow resistance great
I only shattered one iPhone this year I
think that's accomplishments a new
generation of face ID so that will
support multiple angles which is
exciting or wonderful support light over
here Oh gross under angle the best part
about the new angles is supposedly if
your phone is lying flat on a table like
this and you unlock it it'll work let's
see I gotta get like this unlock water
resistance has been dramatically
enhanced so you couldn't keep it under
water for long more than 30 minutes
I know that I've seen tests of people
who have submerged it a hundred water
for long
thirty minutes it's been fine I have had
a lot of water issues with mine and
spills dropped it in the bathtub I
always take my phone in the shower like
that's weird but I do mostly because I'm
usually ordering close mates and I just
want to make sure that they got my order
correctly and if they're on the way and
you know I need the towel off it's the
whole thing
phone and shower totally normal in this
household this has been rumored for a
while that they were going to do away
with 3d touch so that looks like that's
gonna go away which Vanessa doesn't
really make that much of a difference I
actually really did like the 3d touch
third and switching to the haptic
feedback which is much like the iPhone
10 R so that's kind of interesting
they're gonna be calling the 10 R 11 and
then making the iPhone 11 called the I
need a flow chart and your flow chart
now I'm gonna be flashcards to keep all
these phones in order one of the new
colors is a green finish I love it I
freaking love it
you could roast my eyeballs all day long
and the last thing on this list is the
a13 chipset inside the iPhone 11 range
has a new component codenamed AMX or
matrix which offloads
math heavy tasks I don't care what it's
called just do things faster do things
quicker make my face idea and LOC faster
whatever do what you got to do I also a
better battery life no big deal this is
something else a little upset about they
because a mission from the entire I've
got a lot of range is 5g I mean I think
5g isn't obviously wildly available
everywhere so it does make sense that
maybe they're not going to be including
in this version because by 2020 I think
that that will be something that is more
widely accepted in all carriers no doubt
the cyber 11 range is looking more
impressive than - just a few weeks ago
let's see here's the thing we get these
leaks everyone is upset they're like
this isn't what we wanted to get more
leaks for like cool this is what we want
I'm really excited and then we actually
have the event and then really cool
Apple thanks for giving us all these
things that we might not really actually
need but you didn't know that we were
wanting it but you told us that we
wanted it and now I want it even more so
that's classic classic Apple and Justine
relationship I mean at least now I have
my Apple credit
so also 3% cashback on everything that I
buy so I might as well just buy
everything doesn't that make complete
financial sense it doesn't don't listen
to me
iPhone Pro new iPad and 16 inch macbook
pro oh geez yes it's crazy but I was
just thinking the other day I'm like man
I really need a new MacBook I don't I
absolutely do not this laptop has been
through so much I want to show you guys
my little setup that I have here it's
actually I don't know looks really
stupid looks kind of awful but I have
these little velcro whose stickies I am
surprised that it works it works very
well but this is my look so if you ever
see somebody in the airport looking like
this might be me I do need to add
another one I think right here but this
one's a little bit bigger and heavier so
I was a little bit worried about if it
would be able to hold the weight of it
so I guess maybe I might put it here and
then we're all good I am extremely
interested in a 16 inch MacBook Pro
although I do feel like for me this is a
pretty good size I think that you know
if the weight of it is a little bit
heavier that's something that I'm not
gonna be that interested in because I
just want to try to pare down the amount
of things that I travel with like
basically my whole youtube channel my
whole entire life right here looks like
a mess now with the rx100 mark 7 and you
can have audio input I think that's
gonna be pretty much my go-to camera
when I travel I don't know it's just
getting to be too much like I just bring
everything I get to the airport they
detained me for suspicious activity when
I just have like seven cameras and 15
cellphone I'm IRA few things on the
internet not drugs phones so a 16 inch
MacBook Pro I'm interested if it's
lighter God could you imagine if I don't
SD card reader
definitely hold my breath because I'll
be dead that's the case so trimming the
screen bezel could make a 16 inch
MacBook Pro about the same size as the
current 15 inch that's a pretty smart
move right yeah they haven't had a
bigger screen since the 17 inch macbook
that was in 2012 it feels like just
yesterday he's a musical dude well
that's just even the latest Apple news
that I saw I you know wait for the event
still a rumor to be around the 10th so
your calendars get your APRA cards out
and get ready to go shopping I also did
an unboxing with the Apple cards if you
wanna check that out look at our
description and annotation and you know
what to do like it's not your first time
watching YouTube video and this is and
this is your first youtube video that
you're watching ever on YouTube really
sorry I'm so late I mean I guess you
picked a great video to watch look at
some more video
I'll be guys later I don't know where
I'm going we're just gonna get up make
it look like I'm leaving frame it's like
a nice exit